es ist putins krieg gegen die ukraine
darauf hat der bundeskanzler wert gelegt
nicht der krieg des russischen volkes
auf dass sich putin im moment
offensichtlich noch verlassen kann und
diesen rückhalt wird er brauchen vor
allem wenn seine ziele über die ukraine
hinausgehen putin wird inzwischen alles
zugetraut das führt direkt zum titel
unserer sendung krieg in europa wer
stoppt putin jetzt in der phoenix runde
[Musik]
phoenix runde
präsident putin
vergiss das blut jenes volkes
dass er eben noch bruder volk nannte
ich appelliere an präsident putin
stoppen sie den wahnsinn dieses krieges
jetzt
wir sind mit unseren gefühlen und
gedanken bei den menschen in der ukraine
die opfer dieses krieges sind
auch für die menschen in russland wird
das handeln ihres präsidenten bittere
folgen haben ich sage ihnen allen wir
wollen keine feindschaft mit dem
russischen volk im gegenteil
größte besorgnis nicht nur heute beim
bundespräsidenten und damit herzlich
willkommen bei uns meine gäste zunächst
die zugeschalteten egon ramms ist bei
uns general hd der bundeswehr und
ehemalige nato
befehlshabers teltschik ist uns
ebenfalls zugeschaltet der frühere
außenpolitische berater des früheren
bundeskanzlers helmut kohl und auch
lange jahre leiter und chef der münchner
sicherheitskonferenz
hier im studio ist kathrin facebook sind
deutsch amerikanische
politikwissenschaftlerin arbeiten
inzwischen hier in berlin beim global
public policy institute also einem
institut
für globale und globale politik und paul
anton krüger ist bei uns von der
deutschen zeitung hier aus dem
parlaments büro in berlin herr amts
für den laien sieht das ja so aus dass
russland da mit einer gewaltigen
militärschlag
einmarschiert ist oder laie denkt sich
wahrscheinlich eigentlich müsste es ja
mit der ukraine der besetzung der
ukraine ziemlich schnell gehen bei
dieser übermacht ist das eine richtige
einschätzung
also die übermacht der kräfte die russen
einsetzten sind welt bis zu den
streitkräften der ukraine gar nicht so
viel größer
was die russen offensichtlich sehr
geschickt gemacht haben es die haben von
norden angegriffen dem schwerpunkt
richtung tiere offensichtlich war da die
ukraine nicht darauf vorbereitet so
hatte den angriff aus dem osten erwartet
das heißt die ukraine müsse kräftiges
total umgruppieren dort abzuwarten wie
das jetzt geht aber ich denke nicht dass
sie spazieren wird für die russische
stolz ist
putin sei hört man häufiger vom westen
immer wieder desavouiert immer bloß
gestellt worden
bei seinen versuchen auf augenhöhe mit
dem westen zu verhandelnden letzten 30
jahren oder in den letzten 20 jahren
seitdem er dann präsident ist das würde
auch seine rachsucht seine aggressivität
erklären was stimmt daran
also aus meiner
sicht und auf dem hintergrund meiner
erfahrungen
fühlt sich
der russische präsident
nicht immer ernst genommen unser
westlichen seien
beispielsweise sein auftritt auf der
münchner sicherheitskonferenz
die schlagzeile der medien war der tenor
der reaktion ein neuer kalter krieg
beginnt in der sache als solches jedoch
ging es ihm darum
dass er probleme sah in der entscheidung
der amerikanischen regierung
raketenabwehrsysteme in rumänien und
bulgarien
vorzubereiten und er hat was meiner
sicht nicht ganz zu unrecht die
befürchtung gehabt er ist eigentlich
diese abwehrsysteme gegen
russland gerichtet
und das in einer situation
wo er noch bereit war sehr offensiv und
pragmatische zusammenarbeit mit den
europäern zu intensivieren das empfand
als ein stück verraten dessen und wer
eine sie zu wir hatten ja zu diesem
zeitpunkt schon
den nato-russland-rat
wir hatten ihr
und akte nato russland in der ja cuxland
gesagt habe dass die nato kein gegner
sei
auf diesem hintergrund war die frage
wird in der aktuell warum das paket nur
abwehrsystem und die bundeskanzlerin hat
unmittelbar vor wut ihm geredet und hat
auf diesem hintergrund bereits
bestehenden vereinbarungen gesagt wir
müssen darüber hinaus die beziehungen
nato russland weiter entwickeln und
interessanterweise putin ist leider in
seiner rede in staufen eingegangen aber
wieder aber kein einziger teilnehmer der
konferenz hat erstmal die
bundeskanzlerin gefragt wird verstehen
sie denn unter einer weiteren
entwicklung über diese grund aktie
hinaus noch ist putin gefragt wurden
was was sagt sie denn zu solchen wir
wollen sie dem verhältnis gesetzt ein
letztes mehr dafür einsatzzahlen ein
jahr darauf hat der nachfolger präsident
medwedew den vorschlag in berlin auf
einer in seiner rede gemacht in einer
großen programmatischen rede
doch die beziehungen zu russland weiter
zu entwickeln und
signale die offenbar hier im westen auch
nicht registriert worden seine frau wird
sport ohne die usa dürfte putin kaum zu
stoppen sein wie groß ist eigentlich der
rückhalt von schubert in der eigenen
bevölkerung wenn jetzt möglicherweise
von den usa einen noch sehr viel weiter
gehen das militärische engagement in
osteuropa erwartet wird oder auch nötig
ist noch ist der groß und das sollte man
noch mal unterstreichen das ist ganz
interessant weil das mit sicherheit mich
selbstverständlich war denn wir haben
gesehen dass natürlich die
republikanische partei sich in den
letzten und seit dem 6 januar des
letzten jahres immer mehr in diese
tasche bewegung
wieder eingereiht hat und wir haben ein
donald trump gewesen denn nicht nur
während seiner präsidentschaft sondern
jetzt auch in den letzten tagen die
logik eines wladimir putin unterstützt
hat getragen hat wir sehen das auch in
den amerikanischen medien also ist es
vielleicht im umkehrschluss eigentlich
interessant zu sehen wie sehr der
kongress wirklich jetzt zusammen hält
also wie zumindest er in beiden parteien
den rückhalt verspürt die bevölkerung
ist eine andere sache die guckt
natürlich schon auf dinge wie gaspreise
und auf wirtschaftliche
entwicklungsfragen die verstehen für sie
ist die ukraine immer noch weit weg aber
sie verstehen schon diesem duktus des
präsidenten zu sagen hier geht es
wirklich noch mal um die
systemarchitektur und diese ängste des
kalten krieges die sehen wir auch wieder
an amerika auf bilden also noch hat er
den rückhalt die frage ist welche
wirtschaftlichen auswirkungen diese
engmaschigen sanktions pakete haben
werden auch auf die usa und das das wird
entscheidend werden dann könnte das
putin ein aggressor ist das wissen wir
nicht erst seit diesen tagen hat sich
der westen da viel zu lange der
wirklichkeit verweigert
ja diese selbstkritik gibt es ja auch
zum beispiel von der ehemaligen
verteidigungs ministerin annegret kramp
karrenbauer dass man sich nicht
vorbereitet habe ich glaube man hätte
nach der invasion der krim 2014
spätestens wissen müssen dass putin
militärische gewalt wieder als als
mittel der politik in europa sieht und
das ist jetzt noch mal sehr deutlich
geworden dass hat die bundesministerin
in münchen formuliert sie hat dieser
tage hier in berlin noch mal gesagt wir
sind in einer völlig anderen welt
putin greift ja nicht nur die die
territoriale integrität und souveränität
der ukraine an das wäre vielleicht auch
noch ein punkt über den wir sprechen
sollten was eigentlich seine motive da
sind weil das geht ja offenbar weit über
die nato hinaus
so und damit wird man jetzt umgehen
müssen man hätte auch zum beispiel in
syrien sehen können dass
putin militärische gewalt als mittel
einsetzt sechs gruppen los ich meine da
sind ganze wohnviertel in der loipe und
anderen städten einfach in schutt und
asche geborgen worden die ehemalige
bundesverteidigungsminister in annegret
kramp karrenbauer hat jedem gesagt wir
hätten historisch versagt sozusagen
sehenden auges hiermit beispiele genannt
aus dem letzten jahren das war ja alles
bekannt trotzdem ist das passiert ist
mit ihr jetzt immer wieder von dieser
sicherheitsarchitektur in europa
gesprochen diesen begriff hat auch putin
eingeführt dafür stehen die russen etwas
anderes darunter als möglicherweise der
westen sicherheitsarchitektur kann er
nur funktionieren wenn alle sich in
sicherheit fühlen was muss man andere
diesen begriff verstehen wie sieht eine
sicherheitsarchitektur eigentlich heute
und in zukunft in europa aus
also ich glaube das ist bei putin mehr
in der rhetorische figur als dass er das
wirklich ernst meint er versucht ein
grundsatz zb aus der ksc die schlussakte
herauszupicken
und dem zum argument für die russische
sicht der dinge zu machen ja ja sagt die
unteilbarkeit von sicherheit oder der
grundsatz dass ein staat seine
sicherheit nicht auf kosten eines
anderen erhöhen sollte gäbe russland das
recht jetzt zum beispiel diesen
angriffskrieg zu führen russland tritt
seit jahren die prinzipien zb der der
schlussakte von helsinki selber mit
füßen nicht nur im internationalen
bereich also diese kasse regelungen bei
der osze ksc
sehen ja auch zb demokratische
strukturen vor alle staaten bekennen
sich dort zu demokratischen strukturen
russland hat
1994 als die ukraine dann ihre
atomwaffen abgegeben hat an russland
eine sicherheitsgarantie abgegeben im
rahmen von budapest er hat sich immer
wieder auch zu diesen grundsätzen
bekannt und er verstößt jetzt dagegen
und dann muss man halt ein bisschen
danach fragen was sind eigentlich die
gründe er hat ja einige selber genannt
er hat die regierung die demokratisch
gewählte regierung in der ukraine heute
als eine bande von drogenabhängigen und
neonazis bezeichnet und hat die
ukrainische armee aufgerufen gegen diese
demokratisch legitimierte regierung zu
pushen also geht es ihm offenbar um
einen regimewechsel in kiew was eine
ganz andere sache ist als zu sagen okay
es gibt bestimmte interessen russlands
die vielleicht nicht so berücksichtigt
worden sind wie sie berücksichtigt
hätten werden müssen die nato und der
westen hat ja angeboten zb über
rüstungskontrolle wieder mit russland zu
verhandeln und auch da ist die
erzählungen immer ein bisschen einen
seite ja ich hab selber als journalist
darüber berichtet wie der damalige
berater des us präsidenten obama herr
sailer und damals als
bundesaußenminister frank walter
steinmeier zum beispiel versucht haben
den kse-vertrag wo es um konventionelle
streitkräfte in europa geht wieder zu
beleben das am widerstand der russen
gescheitert wir wollten nicht ja also
das ist ein beiderseitiges ding und
nicht so dass russland immer der
benachteiligte partner war das sind
archiv dass putin benutzt aus
politischen gründen absagen ja manche
das was putin jetzt gemacht hat das war
eine art zivilisationsbruch gewesen kann
man mit einem flächenland überhaupt dann
noch verhandeln über sicherheits
architektur oder ist das für lange zeit
unmöglich also ich glaube es ist jetzt
wirklich erst mal bedeutend schwierig
ich meine jetzt haben wir einen
völkerrechts bruch nach dem anderen dem
wir wirklich in die geschichtsbücher
schreiben können und ich sehe das ganze
ähnlich es geht bleibt mir putin nicht
wirklich um die nato weil wenn das der
fall gewesen wäre erstens mal hatte er
durch die verschiedenen
architektonischen elemente die wir eben
in den verhältnissen nato und russland
schon festgelegt haben sehr sehr viel
mitspracherecht gehabt 2001 liebäugelt
mit einem einem beitritt zur nato dass
wir die verlängerung von gorbatschows
europäischen gemeinsamen europäischen
haus gewesen nein es geht diesen dem
russischen staatspräsidenten um die
bedrohung der demokratie
und wenn wenn wir uns die freie
entscheidungsmacht von verschiedenen
völkern und den den georgien den
ukrainern ganz genauso das ist doch das
was ihm wirklich der der dorn im auge
ist und wenn er sich nicht auf diese
grundprinzipien
einlassen kann dazu fanden ich sehe
gerade keine möglichkeit wie man quasi
noch für die kernwerte des westens
einsteht und dann versucht und dann dann
quasi eine eine finanzierung
gegebenenfalls einer ukraine
voranbringen würde das wäre dann ja
schon implizit der bruch des westens mit
dem mit den eigentlichen glauben sie und
rechtsstaat hast dann macht sie erst
recht überhaupt können sie mehr mit ihm
zu verhandeln denn worüber sollte man
darüber verhandeln dass er sich nicht
mit atomwaffen gegenseitig plattmacht
gut aber alles andere ist doch dann sind
ja und vor allem es ist einfach ja auch
eine pervertierung des vokabulars was
wir gesehen haben also nicht nur die
völker rechtsbruch sondern die tatsache
dass er die die soldaten wenn sie in die
ukraine ost ukraine schickt als
friedenskämpfer bezeichnet das einen
jüdischen präsidenten als neonazis sind
hier werden uns westliches vokabular was
wir damals gebraucht haben um den kosovo
einsatz zu begründen das wird uns jetzt
irgendwie umgekehrt und pervertiert um
die ohren gehauen und da ist wirklich
die frage kann man dann wirklich noch
ernsthafte verhandlungen auf der basis
von einer rechtsstaatlichen ordnung und
von recht überhaupt angehen und insofern
glaube ich dass was jetzt der westen
plant die schlinge erst noch enger zu
ziehen und dann zu schauen wir reagiert
es erst mal das richtige vorgehen
teltschik sie haben jahrzehnte lange
erfahrung im umgang erst mit der
sowjetunion später mit russland sie
haben schon vor 1989 als
außenpolitischer berater des
bundeskanzlers damals mit gorbatschow
mit der sowjetischen
administration verhandelt natürlich erst
1989 990 zwei plus vier verhandlungen
und auch dann die entwicklung der
sowjetunion später russlands dann an
entscheidender an wichtiger stelle mit
verfolgt wenn sie das jetzt heute auch
hören dass putin da sagt über sind
neonazis an der macht die wird unter
drogeneinfluss stehen diese wortwahl
dieses vokabular diese begriffsbildung
was hat sich da in den letzten 30 jahren
geändert in moskau
also
mein
zugang
interesse im umgang mit russland
hat immer darin bestand dass wir
aufgrund unserer geschichte mit zwei
weltkriegen
ein interesse haben müssen unabhängig
wie russland sichern und das stück
mit russland einen modus vivendi des
zusammenlebens zu finden der 1 der
kriege verhindern also nach zwei haben
wir ja nun wirklich genug
wechselseitigen
katastrophen sie darf jetzt nicht
vorgenommen hatten steht jetzt
deutschland steht er schon jetzt vor
einem scherbenhaufen
wir stehen vor einem scherbenhaufen der
diesen fall von putin ausgehen
russland bleibt nach wie vor unser
nachbar und ist nach wie vor eines der
stärksten von atomar gerüstete
nationen dieser welt und hat
die nato auch versäumt hat über den
nato-russland-rat
wirklich das thema abrüstung
rüstungskontrolle voran
das abkommen also die das abkommen über
die begrenzung von
mittelstreckenraketen aufgefunden wir
haben keine vertrauensbildende maßnahmen
wirklich
weiterentwickelt und
intensiviert genutzt und und und da gibt
es auch viele fehlleistungen und
versäumnis auf unser er kann ich nur
sagen
wir für was hatten wir die nato russland
rat in
den entscheidenden phasen nicht zusammen
gekommen ist und wenn dann nur auf
botschafter ebene die keine entscheidung
also
wir müssen wir haben die chancen die wir
sie sich angeboten haben nicht wirklich
optimal genutzt ramms wenn dir ganz kurz
auf die aktuelle situation in der
ukraine noch mal sehen was passiert in
einem solchen krieg mit zivilisten gibt
es ein blutvergiessen gibt es schlimme
kriegsverbrechen ich habe ja gerade
schon
sie gefragt nach den möglichkeiten die
da die russische armee hat lässt sich
denn eine stadt wie kiew lässt sich die
ukraine die ja ein zwar großes aber auch
sehr flaches land ist ohne grosse
gebirgszüge die man leichter verteidigen
kann lässt sich die ukraine wirklich und
lässt sich kiel gegen diese russische
über macht verteidigen auf dauer
auf dauer sicherlich nicht wenn die
übermacht ihren schwerpunkt auf tiere
schlecht die frage ist aber ob der
schwerpunkt tatsächlich auf kiel gelegt
wird kann sein weil putin
beziehungsweise rutschen befehlshaber
die regierung und kommunikation städten
militärische führung der gleichen jahr
bekommen wollen das heißt eine
verteidigung auf dauer ist nicht möglich
aber es bleibt abzuwarten wie die
ukraine jetzt ihre kräfte möglicherweise
neu ordnet und wie weit sie den russen
in einigen bereichen zumindest paroli
bieten kann ist sich abzuzeichnen dass
der vormarsch der russen doch nicht mehr
ganz so schnell geht wie er gestern
begonnen hat von der empfehlung von
meiner seite her die nächsten tage mal
haben wollten sich die lage dort
entwickelt nicht ins exil bevölkerung
das wird nicht ohne verluste bei der
zivilbevölkerung abgehen das ist ein
hartes wort selbst wenn die
zivilbevölkerung schutz sucht und
dergleichen mehr wir haben bereits
gesehen dass offensichtlich wohnblocks
in kiel beschlossen worden sind die
weder militärische einrichtung der sonst
irgendwelche einrichtungen enthalten
oder lou die zivilbevölkerung betroffen
ist und daher das wird sich nicht
ausschließen lassen wie schätzen sie die
kampfkraft der ukrainischen armee ein
mann sagt er diese sei in europa wächst
der russischen armee die zweitstärkste
dh sie hat durchaus potenzial der
widerstand erfolgreich widerstand zu
leisten
da geht es zunächst um die zahlen also
die die ukraine ist nur europa gerechnet
die türkei ausgelassen die zweitstärkste
armee die wir in europa
die armee war im jahr 2014 in einem sehr
desolaten zustand das hat sich bis heute
geändert nicht durch neue waffensystem
um dergleichen mehr sogar bestenfalls
durch
regierungs meistern neue funkgeräte neue
kommunikationsberatung dergleichen mehr
was sich geändert hat war aus den
desolaten zustand der einstellung der
soldaten im jahr 2014 beim
demokratischen soldaten heute
offensichtlich den willen ihr vaterland
zu verteidigen und das wird sich zeigen
wie sich das dann möglicherweise gegen
entsandte soldaten aus den aus der aus
russland auswirken wird ob das sind ja
in kriegs- entscheidender grund wird
seine frage die ich heute nicht
beantworten können man redet ja schon
von guerilla und häuserkampf ist das
auch eine mögliche entwicklung
also dieser bereich ist auch
geschichtlich für partisanenkämpfer und
dergleichen bekannt von daher eignet
sich das land trotz seiner flachheit
aufgrund der bewaldung und der
bodenbedeckung möglicherweise doch dafür
partisanenkämpfer zu machen
beispielsweise aus den sumpfgebieten
heraus die wir im lauf des daniel bahr
haben
die ukrainische regierung aber auch
viele ukrainer aus sich heraus möchte
offensichtlich mit hoher intensität ihr
vater dann verteidigen das heißt wenn
die ukrainische streitkräfte geschlagen
sind geht möglicherweise ein punkt nennt
das terror krieg ich das partisanenkampf
wenn wir mal jetzt auf die möglichkeiten
sehen die der westen da hat nicht
militärisch einzugreifen das kann dann
dass viele auch gar nicht also mit
sanktionen reichen diese jetzt geplanten
sanktionen aus als sie werden mit jedem
tag schärfer und sie werden mit jedem
tag zielgenauer also wir sind wie wir
jetzt zusammensetzen haben wir gerade
gehört das natürlich jetzt herr putin
und hella beruf direkt angegangen werden
sollen durch sanktionen also die die die
schlinge zieht sich immer enger aber wie
wir eben schon angesprochen haben dauern
sanktionen in ihrer wirkung immer länger
als das was im zweifel auf dem
kriegsfeld sich abspielt ein paar andere
sachen hat der westen auch noch in der
in der westentasche sagen immer so und
zwar ist es das ganze thema cyber und
wir sehen gerade das eben zusätzlich zu
dem was ich jetzt auf dem eigentlichen
kriegsschauplatz abspielt natürlich
gerade in der nehmen in der cyber arena
es ähnlich zugeht beziehungsweise
da sowohl auf moskau und auf
infrastruktur in russland angriff
genommen wird wenn man es möchte cyber
offensiv gearbeitet wird und umgekehrt
eben auch und die frage die sich die
nato jetzt stellen muss mit den cyber
kapazitäten diese gegebenenfalls haben
würden und dazu kommen natürlich noch
der ganze eurovision.de
kapazitäten können dafür auch im wissen
genau genau aber das ist eben genau der
punkt also wir warten jetzt alle auf
dieses neue strategische konzept im mai
wo sich die nato vielleicht dazu
durchringen soll auch cyber offensiven
mit in ihren vertrag aufzunehmen aber so
weit sind sie noch nicht und wir haben
eine nato architektur die natürlich auf
konsens basiert also das sind die dinge
die es gerade für die für die nato an
sich noch schwierig machen könnten aber
das ist natürlich auch einzelnen länder
innerhalb des nordatlantischen
bündnisses da könnte es auch einige
gentlemen agreement geben da auch auf
der cyber dimension zurück zu drücken
denn da ist nämlich die frage könnte
auch ein artikel 5 fall ausgelöst werden
wenn zum beispiel die ruß und attacken
vor allem gegen kritische infrastruktur
die dann gegebenenfalls auch so sind
technologische netzwerke gestrickt
vielleicht polnische oder andere
europäische ziele einfach mit einnehmen
ist das dann schon ein artikel 5 fall
und in welcher art müsse die nato möchte
man aber dann auch mit cyber-attacken
dagegen halten also nicht mit
konventionellen militärischen also das
ist genau der punkt und ich glaube das
sind die dinge die in den hinterzimmern
in brüssel jetzt sehr vehement
diskutiert werden denn das ist eben die
neue dimension eines ganz modernen
krieges herr krüger häufig doch wieder
ganz cool
dass frau koch gerade geschrieben hat
ist woran sie das sagt das thema bei der
nato aber wir müssen bitte auch im auge
haben dass es juristen gibt vor allen
dingen in deutschland juristen gibt die
sagen ein cyberangriff ist ein eingriff
und dann gleich das grundgesetz das
heißt dann
müsste der bundestag dem zu stehen
nein nicht nur allein das wäre ein
verstoß gegen grundgesetz angriffskriege
sind verboten so steht es bei uns im
grundgesetz und wenn man einen
cyberangriff als angriff bezeichnet er
definiert hat deutschland ein problem
und das ist auch der grund warum dieses
thema bei der nato in den letzten jahren
ich formuliere das vorsichtig sehr
langsam von
hernandez will dann wieder auf wieder
tolle aktionen aber dann könnt ihr
natürlich jetzt wenn das eine eine
gegenwehr ist natürlich auch von einer
abwehrmaßnahme sprechen und dann wäre es
ja durch das grundgesetz gedeckt
ja nur die jungs müssen sich darüber
einig werden und sie müsste ich ja
schnell darüber einig werden dann wird
das was frau gruber spruch gerade
beschrieben hat in brüssel auch
tatsächlich in diesem jahr passieren
kann es gibt es ja verschiedene
möglichkeiten die der westen hat eine
andere wäre das was der
botschafter der ukraine in berlin
sozusagen das ziemlich lautstark
vernehmliche sprache oder ukraine hier
in deutschland botschafter melnik auch
gefordert hat neben noch schärferen
sanktionen auch jetzt doch
waffenlieferungen defensiver waffen für
die ukrainische armee kann die
bundesregierung bei ihrem strikten nein
da bleiben
als das nein wird ja schon ein stückchen
aufgeweicht man liefert jetzt 5000 helme
und das ist auf dem wege und man
defensivwaffen aber eigentlich ist ja
man ja überlegt andere militärausrüstung
das problem ist dass man halt mal sich
die bestände bei der bundeswehr
angeguckt hat und noch nicht sagte ein
regierungsmitglied ja nachtsichtgeräte
die hätten wir selber einmal gerne die
werden wir nicht liefern können weil wir
sie schlichtweg nicht haben das ist ein
problem da kann es vielleicht auch was
zu sagen was den ausrüstungsstand der
bundeswehr angeht was man glaube ich
nicht machen wird ist waffensysteme im
eigentlichen sinne wie diese haubitzen
und dies dagegen die in estern stehenden
aus ehemaligen nva beständen kommen oder
milan panzerabwehrraketen wie wir das
irgendwie bei den kunden gemacht haben
zu liefern
das ist ein bisschen eine frage wie man
das einschätzt ob es tatsächlich jetzt
noch zu einer langen auseinandersetzung
kommt und man sagt okay wir
geben den ukraine mittel an die hand so
lange wie nötig
widerstand zu leisten gegen
eine mögliche russische besatzungsmacht
ich glaube nicht dass russland ein
großes interesse daran hat dass putin
hat das mehrfach gesagt das land
wirklich dauerhaft zu besetzen oder
müssen sie einen
substanziellen anteil ihrer streitkräfte
dauerhaft in der ukraine stationieren
und er weiß glaube ich die russische
führung sehr gut was das für sie für das
land und auch für das was dann in der
ukraine oder auf dem ukrainischen
territorium passieren würde bedeuten
würde die fähigkeiten der bundeswehr
werden wir gleich noch in diesem
zusammenhang liegen hat angie kann sich
noch eine frage wenn jetzt
waffenlieferungen das sind wir ja nicht
nur in spannungsgebiete sondern das wäre
in dem fall sogar eine waffenlieferung
oder waffenlieferungen ein kriegsgebiet
muss die bundesrepublik die
jahrzehntelang eine völlig es an völlig
anderes prinzip verfolgt hat muss sie da
jetzt muss die bundesrepublik da über
ihren schatten springen im notfall wenn
es keine andere möglichkeit gibt die
ukraine zu retten
also wenn man die waffenlieferungen
ernsthaft in erwägung
gezogen hätte hätten wir viel früher
beginnen müssen richtigen zeitpunkt
gemacht nicht das vorrangige thema
dessen sie heute kam die nachricht dass
der creme ein verhandlungsangebot an die
eu keine gemacht hat und dass viel los
gesprochen werden umgekehrt hat die
ukraine verhandelt angebot russland
gemacht der zoll in warschau an das
heißt doch dass der kriegs verlaufen in
der ukraine
anscheinend nicht zu verläuft wie sich
russland das selbst vorgestellt können
aber auch musik hat sein welche angebote
könnten aber auch neben katzen seien
unsere angebote
ja das muss mal prüfen aber ich
bin eher für politische lösungen
um meine erfahrung ist er erstmal
angebote
ernst ja und dem partner ernst zu nehmen
auch wenn man erwischt
und sicher gibt es jetzt viele sagen es
hat keinen sinn mit putin zu sprechen
das verstehe ich hat meine sympathie
aber wenn er jetzt bereit ist die
verhandlung dann sollte man das testen
und
wie weit das dann die militärische
auseinandersetzungen ein stück reduziert
oder
im zweifel muss es im militärischen
auseinandersetzungen reduzieren sonst
kommen halten ein solches
verhandlungsangebot klein sind
wenn es jetzt zu einer solchen
reduzierung der militärischen
aktivitäten nicht kommen die angst geht
ja auch um dass dieser krieg weiter aus
greift nach westen möglicherweise in
nato gebiet und das würde uns ja dann
unmittelbar betreffen da entsteht an der
artikel 5 des nato-vertrags gegenseitig
beistand je nachdem welches nato-land da
angegriffen wird das heißt wie gut ist
die bundeswehr da eigentlich aufgestellt
wenn ich das richtig gelesen haben sie
gestern noch im zdf gesagt werden auch
nicht in der lage unser eigenes land zu
verteidigen wie können wir dann anderen
helfen
also wir helfen im augenblick anderen
unterstützen die ihn mit den
streitkräften oder teil mit ihnen allen
teilstreitkräften und mit den soldaten
wo wir eine verpflichtung in der nato
reingegangen sind das ist einmal die
nähte response force das ist einmal die
barry heiratete jones task force und
denen wir uns beteiligen und wir haben
dann noch einige weitere soldaten wie
beispielsweise die 350 die zusätzlich
nach litauen entsandt worden sind die
praktisch ich sage mal aus der alten die
ttf noch da sind und die eigentliche
eine übung in litauen brief für und
sollten aus dem grunde geht es etwas
früher ins antworten sind die aussage
des inspekteurs des heeres das wenn man
über diese ganz für das heer
betrachteten 16.000 soldaten darüber
welche geht das er dann blank ist diese
aussage ist zutreffend wir haben nach
wie vor nicht für alle truppenteile die
entsprechende ausrüstung das
entsprechende material
truppenteile jetzt auch für die kommende
tfv wieder in verantwortung kommen 2023
müssen sich wieder material ausleihen
das ziel was 2016 mit weiss' buch und
2017 gesetzt worden ist mit dem
fähigkeitsprofil der bundeswehr im jahre
2023 eine voll einsatzbereite aus sich
einsatzbereite brigade zu haben werden
wir nicht erreichen das ist auch nicht
mehr möglich auf der zeitachse bis zum
nächsten jahr und wir werden es auch
nicht schaffen bis zum jahr 2027
das war auch ein teil aus der konzeption
der bundeswehr und dem fähigkeitsprofil
die erste von einsatz aus sich heraus
von einsatz heute die vision zu haben
von da ist die aussage von generale und
meist richtig neben der verpflichtung
die wir weiterhin erfüllen können ist so
gut wie nichts mehr da was kann man da
sagen dann ist die bundeswehr richtig
recht erodierte man das jetzt vielleicht
zeitfenster bis 2023 bis 2027 in dieser
zeit kann wer weiß was in europa
passieren was ist eigentlich der
bundeswehr gemacht worden was ist mit
der bundeswehr stehen beziehungsweise
was hat die politik zu verantworten im
umgang mit der bundeswehr in den letzten
drei jahrzehnten na ja man hat halt
geglaubt dass es
lange zeit geglaubt dass
bündnisverteidigung nicht mehr das thema
ist es gab die einsätze in afghanistan
und andere daten an die bundeswehr
umgebaut zu einer einsatzarmee und hat
aber zugleich nicht sozusagen eine basis
dass vorgehalten was man innerhalb der
nato
und und auch zur landes- und
bündnisverteidigung eben braucht da hat
es eigentlich 2014 den auf weg moment
gegeben mit der inversion auf der krim
dass man gesagt hat das wird jetzt
wieder wichtiger und wir müssen wieder
zurück
aber das geht natürlich nicht von heute
auf morgen da geht es um ein großgerät
da geht es um ausrüstung da geht es auch
um ausbildung und training das dauert
und was natürlich seit jahren ein
dauerthema ist und vor der wahl auch
noch irgendwie so hingestellt wurde als
ob das nur die bösen amerikaner sind die
jetzt hier irgendwie von uns was fordern
ist das halt die verteidigungsausgaben
nicht annähernd da sind wo wir
selbst in der nato zugesagt haben dass
ihnen kommen sollen dass das bekannte
zwei prozent ziel das hat sich jetzt die
ampel koalition etwas anders verpackt
neu formuliert 3% für außen sicherheit
verteidigung aber da sind im prinzip
wenn man das durchrechnen 2 prozent für
für die verteidigung drin und da muss
man halt auch sehen dass man selbst wenn
man leicht aufwachsen im
verteidigungshaushalt hat das noch nicht
heißt dass man die lücken die in den 20
jahren entstanden sind schließen kann
weil es gibt eine inflation die gehälter
der soldatinnen und soldaten steigen das
wird mehr oder weniger aufgefressen sie
haben reihenweise großgerät das ersetzt
werden muss dass im prinzip am ende
seiner lebensdauer ist es in die tornado
kampfjets das sind die schweren
transporthubschrauber bei der marine ist
es so dass sie im prinzip sagen die
fregatte bayern weil es gerade daraufhin
pazifik masse mission wenn sie in der
nato ihre verpflichtungen erfüllen
wollen da war es glaube ich die nächsten
fünf bis sieben jahre vergessen ja wir
haben einfach kein schiff das wir dafür
so eine mission irgendwie losschicken
indem sie muss es dann aus dem
mittelmeer in die ostsee schicken nur
dann funktioniert das verlegt es heißt
ja immer von von westlicher seite jetzt
richtung putin ja du bist ein ganz hohen
preis bezahlen den wieder spüren er soll
die geschlossenheit des westens nicht
unterschätzen schon an die tatsache dass
man darauf hinweisen muss dass
möglicherweise jemand denkt dass der
westen gar nicht so geschlossen ist was
nützt das alles wenn die militärischen
fähigkeiten der nato offensichtlich
nicht im allerbesten zustand sind also
eine sache ist ganz klar dass zum
beispiel diese vielbeschworene
europäische souveränität die sich dann
stützen soll auf all die schönen
akronyme die wir uns innerhalb der
europäischen union gegeben haben für die
projekte zum beispiel auch mit der nato
peskow card der europäische der
defensive fand der das quasi alles
finanzieren soll dass das alles viel zu
langsam ist denn wenn es hart auf hart
kommt und das haben wir in münchen auch
noch mal auf der sicherheitskonferenz
gehört in den diskussionen am sonntag
wenn die französische
verteidigungsministerium und der
europäische außenbeauftragte sagen sie
habe diese dinge sind doch gerade erst
ganz am anfang also mit einer
entschuldigung aber wir reden seit den
90er jahren darüber wie europäische
verteidigungspolitik
europas gestärkt werden soll also das
finden denn da hat da kommt mir wirklich
das blut also was was man da
unterstreicht muss ist dass wir ohne die
amerikaner und sagen ist dann ganz
ehrlich in dem sinne aufgeschmissen
wären und das heißt die europäische
verantwortung muss nicht nur seien dem
steuerzahler zu erzählen man würde jetzt
relativ schnell an europäische
souveränität kommen das liegt wohl auf
der hand dass das nicht geleistet werden
kann sondern umgekehrt müssen wir
schauen wie wir die amerikaner weiter
auch in das europäische theater
einbinden können denn eigentlich das ist
ja klar wollen die amerikaner sich
konzentrieren auf das was im indopazifik
und in dem südchinesischen meer sich
abspielt und der bedrohungslage in asien
und da müssen wir jetzt genau schauen
wie kriegen wir genau dieses thema
burden sharing hin wenn wir es nicht
durch die bundeswehr leisten dann
vielleicht von der
verteidigungsministerium das
vielzitierte
absicherung der ukrainischen wirtschaft
der ukrainischen energieversorgung dann
müssen wir eben wenn andere auf andere
art und weise auf ganze deutsche art und
weise wieder in die bresche springen
aber das muss sich gut verteilen denn
sonst sehen wir wirklich sehr sehr klein
aus den usa diese legendäre
friedensdividende von der wir gedacht
haben 1990 sie trägt uns sind alle zeit
und ewigkeit und die ist aufgezehrt die
ist in jedem fall auf gefährt also wenn
ich an meine eigene lebenszeit denker
und wie wir in deutschland auch als
exportmacht profitiert haben von diesen
gegebenheiten um von der globalisierung
jetzt ist die zeit in die bresche zu
springen und leisten quasi hier
zurückzugeben was wovon wir jetzt über
die letzten gerade über die letzten 30
jahre profitiert haben und das muss sehr
sehr schnell gehen und das wird uns auch
was kosten
ich würde gerne diese anregung von
frühstück mal aufnehmen was jetzt
was sie gesagt hat das ja auch wir über
den tellerrand hinaus gucken müssen
indopazifik viel da als stichwort
ostasien die neue supermacht china
bestehen auch eine gefahr in diesem
konflikt dass es tatsächlich zu einer
achse moskau peking kommt die dann den
westen also zumindest europa richtig in
gefahr bringen könnte und die usa auch
ins schwitzen denn sie hätte dann ja an
zwei fronten zu kämpfen als nato-partner
in europa und als verteidiger der
republik taiwan in asien
ja
also ich erinnere immer
russische gesprächspartner daran dass
der letzte kunde militärische konflikt
den sie hatten ja mit china war und zwar
in den 60er jahren der musik konflikt
und ich selbst habe in china oft erlebt
unmöglich lesen
heute gezeigt haben brücken gezeigt
haben wir berichtet haben das hätten die
russen angefangen zu bauen seien zu über
nacht abgezogen das haben die chinesen
nicht vergessen umgekehrt ich habe mit
den russen diskutiert wie chinesen
lebten schon in
sibirien und ich habe den damaligen
kremlchef gesagt bei uns
passieren zahlen in der größenordnung
von zwei millionen chinesen so viel ist
eins nicht ist ein erster 200.000 aber
das ist ja eine ganze menge und der
sinosol ethnische konflikt den wir in
den 60er jahren hat ist deshalb zustande
gekommen weil
zeitung mit mit indien einen
grenzkonflikt hatte und die
erwartet hat uns kraft hat das abgelehnt
und der daraus entstanden solche kurzen
das heißt
ich finde ja diese
militärischen
spielereien haben und welche wir mehr
haben sollten und so weiter alles
interessant und wichtig aber ich finde
politischen rahmenbedingungen stimmen
wird nicht wir haben einmal kohl hat
1988 mit frankreich versucht eine
initiative zu ergreifen zu eine
gemeinsame europäische außen und
sicherheitsgründen das war damals
innerhalb der europäischen gemeinschaft
nicht möglich weil margaret thatcher
nicht im traum daran sagte sich an einer
solchen idee zusätzlich aber wir haben
einen deutsch-französischen
sicherheitsrat gegründet die eine
integrierte brikada auf die nur das ist
nicht weiter gegangen gab es heute keine
gemeinsame europäische außen- und
sicherheitspolitik wir wollen wir dann
in konflikten militäreinsätzen
europäisches im europäischen rahmen
durch piraten das heißt als das telefon
wird
also quasi alleine eine wie ein
wesentlicher aspekt ist auch dass die
europäer einfach zwei jetzt im moment
zusammengezuckt sind wegen putin und des
überfalls auf die ukraine das sie aber
institutionell überhaupt nicht
aufgestellt sind dieses gerede sag ich
jetzt mal über die gas die gemeinsame
außen und sicherheitspolitik die seit
jahrzehnten gibt rolf sent schicker das
gesagt hat nicht weitergeführt und jetzt
stehen wir sozusagen im hemd da ja vor
einigen nicht mit der schnelligkeit die
russen haben das komplette
nukleararsenal bis zum letzten jahr
wieder neue nivelliert und wieder
hergestellt hätte hatte schon
angesprochen aber wir haben ja noch
einen nuklearen abwehr vertrag an denen
wir uns bei allen denen sich beide
seiten halten nämlich news tat dann
haben die russen überraschend für die
europäer hyperschall waffen vorgestellt
im letzten sommer ahadi nato rüstet da
noch nach aber ist ja auch noch
einigermaßen am anfang die amerikaner
geben sehr viel gas umgekehrt haben sich
die russen eine rückversicherung geholt
mit den chinesen und wir haben heute
wieder gesehen dass der russische
staatspräsident sehr wohl mit shipping
noch mal gesprochen hat weil es jetzt
über entscheidungen im un-sicherheitsrat
geht und wir haben natürlich auch die
absprache gesehen um die olympischen
spiele herum die gasverträge die
energielieferung verträge und jetzt geht
es darum wird china wir haben den
chinesischen außenminister gehört in
münchen sich auf diese idee der
souveränität berufen nämlich das nicht
eingreifen da schwang mit dass man einen
übergriff auf die ukraine verurteilen
würde aber jetzt sind ein paar tage ins
land gegangen und jetzt scheint es eben
doch so dass trotz der probleme die
hätte dick unterstrichen hat zwischen
china und russland ist wenn es hart auf
hart zu kommen scheint die autokratien
doch im sinne des system wettkampfs
zusammenhalten wollen also wie gesagt da
tut sich eine ganz neue eine gefährliche
eine friedlichere kluft noch auf krüger
das heißt also nicht nur die bundeswehr
hat man material mäßig nicht
weiterentwickelt wird nicht sagen auch
verraten dass es vielleicht ein zu
harter begriff man hat aber auch in
politisch strategischen bereich einfach
alle viere grade sein lassen und erntet
jetzt diese diese situation für europa
die viel so gefährlich erscheint ja ich
glaube es ist schon so dass man
konzeptionell oft auch denkt fall war
es sind aber auch viele dinge einfach
beschlossen worden zum beispiel auf der
europäischen ebene oder auch immer an
der nato zum beispiel was an kräften
vorgehalten werden weil
soldini befüllt worden sind also diese
schnelle eingreiftruppe der eu
die muss man halt auch mit irgendwas
unterfüttern er wenn sie irgendwie 5000
mann auf dem papier stehen haben sie
können aber 1000 nur mobilisieren dann
kann man sich fragen wohin der wert von
so einer politischen erklärung liegt ich
glaube da muss man dann schon irgendwie
auch wenn man über die eigenständigkeit
oder hier in berlin sagt man glaube ich
über die souveränität europas redet in
sicherheitspolitischer hinsicht neu
denken und da weil man in berlin auch
lange nicht zu breit der französische
präsident marco hat eine rede gehalten
vor der französischen militär akademie
bei der de facto angeboten hat den
französischen nuklear schirm mit
deutschland oder anderen europäischen
staaten zu teilen da war die die
reaktion erst mal
müssen wir haben nur noch eine minute
heran die spiegel -affäre 1962 ist
ausgelöst worden durch einen artikel
über die nato die sie sei nur bedingt
abwehrbereit
das bezog auch die bundeswehr natürlich
ein könnte man das heute wieder sagen
über das westliche bündnis
das westliche bündnis nicht über die
bundeswehr vielleicht ja das westliche
bündnis hat sich eigentlich in den
letzten jahren relativ gut aufgestellt
viel getan 360° verteidigung aber die
leistungsfähigkeit ist natürlich
abhängig von der leistungsfähigkeit der
streitkräfte mitglieder und da hat der
europäische pfeiler nachholbedarf gut
dann müssen an dieser stelle einen punkt
machen dieses thema wird leider ja in
den nächsten tagen und wochen noch
weitergehen ich bedanke mich bei kathrin
klug bei paul anton krüger bei horst
teltschik und bei egon ramms liebe
zuschauer am sonntag um 11 uhr tritt der
bundestag zu einer sondersitzung
zusammen einziger tagesordnungspunkt
eine regierungserklärung des
bundeskanzlers olaf scholz mit
darauffolgender aussprache und danach
gegen 14.15 gibt es eine phoenix runde
eine internationale phoenix runde mit
dem titel krieg in europa wie schaut die
welt auf putin wir werden den blick also
ganz global weiter bleiben sie bei uns
[Musik]